généreux
passionné
motivé
bonjour bonjour ça va ça va ça Willy
Mami président du Pelot club du Chaudron
depuis le 4 mars
2013 finalise la liste des trucs que N
doit acheter ce matin aujourd'hui not
prépare la journée sportive au féminin
depuis 2 jours avant nous l' un petit
peu bon sous pression euh pour la mise
en place pour l'organisation tout ça ben
là on a tous les affaires du club hein
on a les papiers on a l'imprimante
l'ordinateur aussi vient ici donc
pourquoi tu fais rentrer le club dans ta
vie comme ça mais trouve que min a
quelque chose à devoir à ce club là
parce que c'était quand même un club que
l'enseigne moins pas mal de choses il
donne beaucoup de son temps c'est de sa
personne c'est c'est toute la bah la
pelote c'est c'est sa vie quoi en fait
ça va faire 15 ans que je suis avec lui
et ça va faire depuis 15 ans que voilà
il est corps et âme dans dans la pelote
on va aller à la pelote basque
aujourd'hui tu vas aller voir tes
copines prête pour la
journée on est où là c'est ta deème
maison ben on on va dire ça comme ça
donc voilà le gymnas du Chaudron la
salle de sport Jean gar tu habites tout
ça où avant dans cette même rue
papa
bonjour c'est qui alors bonjour monsieur
c'est le daron le daron oui toute mon
enfance la espace ici devant le gymnase
tout autour du gymnase quoi heureusement
que ce lieu il existe pour montrer aussi
que a des sportifs que n'a point que des
casseurs et des briseur quoi tu as quoi
comme titre sportif en fait au niveau
régional championnat championnat réunion
euh franchement m Guer pu Guer pas dit
peut-être 15 un truc comme ça
et titre
national de fois ch une France c'est
énorme
oui en attendantp il arrive
va commence faci ça fa commence faire
les préparations toujours comme ça nous
per pas trop de
temps voilà il y a un an de cela un peu
plus d'un an de cela oui donc je bien
fait la fête de temps en temps bon il y
a eu un petit incident je me suis énervé
et voilà j'ai donné un coup de PO dans
dans une vite et bon je suis passé pas
très
loin de de la mort quoi ça a tout
sectionné le ner l're tout ça je pense
qu'il a dû prendre conscience de bah de
de de ce qu' la la la réalité de la vie
de de de ce qu'il fallait à un moment
donné Ben se dire bah qu'il fallait
donner un peu de de son temps il l'a pas
lâché en temps normal quelqu'un voilà il
va plus se soigner il va voilà il va se
concentrer là-dessus lui il se soigne et
en même temps ben il reintègre le
comment dire le PUL il pousse plus loin
donc il en veut quoi et c'est c'est ça
qui fait que ça ça force aussi en gros
c'est
ça on passe par là au début c'était
moins tes brosses la table tu tu es fait
un peu de tout quoi donc aujourd'hui
comme il les jeunes il refait pareil ben
dit dit à moins que B il suiv le bon
chemin et que un jour mi espère que je
va devenir des grands champions du moins
notre équipe il travaille pour que
demain les jeunes ils deviennent des
grands champions on se comprend on sait
par comment le gamin il passe on sait
par rapport à nous donc nous on est
passé sait jamais vraiment quel gamin à
quoi comment ils réagissent mais là ils
se sent
considérés
vois
ça vous a jamais choqué que que la
culture basque soit dans le chaudron
comme ça euh si ça nous a choqué on
savait pas du tout où c'était situé et
cetera donc le fait d'être rentré dans
le club ça nous a permis de pouvoir
savoir qu'il y avait une région au
niveau de la France Ctait une région
avec des une culture une culture bien à
eux quoi comme nous en fait comme la
culture rignonnaise avec le propre
spécialité et donc bah ça nous a
vraiment permis de découvrir une une
autre
culture ça fait tout un président oui
ben obligé povalent
hein moi je le connaissais un petit peu
parce que je l'avais entraîné quand
j'étais entraîneur de l'équipe de France
espoir et donc je l'avais eu sur la
préparation physique et j'avais vu que
déjà c'était un leader il a il a du
charisme c'est quelqu'un qui rassemble
si quelqu'un doit redresser le club et
va le faire c'est Willy avec avec bien
il a pas fait tout seul avec Stéphanie
sa femme et avec tous ses amis mais
c'est lui qui a qui a impulsé et c'est
lui qui impulse encore les dam là c'est
qui ben c'est la championne du monde à
baline du monde oui du
monde la classe la classe ben c'est
voilà et aprs donc après nous va faire
de l'initiation faire un Peet peu ça
histoire de bien te gérer c'est
parti à
toi
importe les résultat comme à moins c'est
voilà c'est du moment a passé un bon
moment que tout va bien se passé il a
pas eu d'incident d'accident donc
Mo le développement de la pelote c'est
ça la priorité pour nous c'est ça parce
que c'est par là que toutes les choses
commencent en fait de rester avec ce
grand sourire et et cette convivialité
qui le caractérise et puis j'ai envie de
lui souhaiter d'un point de vue
personnel de revenir très vite dans le
haut niveau parce que c'est avant tout
c'est un sportif de haut niveau c'est
voilà c'est vraiment devenu quelqu'un
d'autre en fait c'est ça lui a permis
vraiment deevenir quelqu'un d'autre tout
à fait totalement
de une façon de penser une façon de voir
les choses O à moi c'est jamais un perd
de temps mais c'est de toujours de
l'expérience de
gagner laisse
tranquille